If you could turn into an animal
what animal would you be and why?
This is like "Willow."
Kind of.
Yeah.
I see the connection there. Awesome.
Perfect.
I didn't, again, still I'm
ignorant of the plot of
"Willow" so I don't know.
And I know this shocks you
Gourley, but I don't know
what it has to do,
but now I know, I guess,
it has something to do
with humans turning into.
Well, it's kind of like
"Ladyhawke" or "Crawl," so
Matt. I am.
Oh Matt.
Oh God.
I am as lost as I've ever been.
Oh, sure. Okay. Anyway,
What animal would I want to turn into?
Well, definitely not one
that can jump in the sea.
I always think that's whenever someone
like Aquaman or there's
some creature that's,
or some person that says yeah
but I can jump in the ocean
and turn into a fish, I think
yeah, but you're so restricted
in your movements, right.
You have to wait for a crime
to be committed underwater
And that just doesn't
happen too often. You know,
you're basically, people
are trying to ask you,
can you get under there and
get the barnacles off my boat?
I don't want to dry dock it.
So I'm gonna say I want it to be,
oh, okay. I'd like to be a grizzly.
I'm fascinated by grizzly bears.
I would love to be able to turn
into a grizzly bear at will.
And I'd like to be able
to stand up on two legs
and rub my back against
a giant Redwood tree.
You should do that now.
Would you wear a diaper?
Like would you put on a diaper
and kinda like go like that?
Oh, no.
Put some background music and
No, there,
You can also do that now.
Some classical music. And
would you do that a lot, or?
Would that classical theme
be Flight of the Bumblebees?
Right, right, right.
Okay. Yes, I get it.
No, I do not wanna be the
Masturbating Bear, and by the way
you're talking about
something I can do now.
I, yes, I can scratch my back now
but when you're a grizzly
and you rub your back against
a giant tree, people see a
tree shaking, 15 miles away
and they know somewhere a
grizzly is satisfying himself.
Is it a sexual thing or is it just,
he's got an itch he can't reach?
No, it's an itch on the
back. But also sometimes
trees mount, sometimes
grizzly bears mount a tree
from the front and that's sexual.
Oh.
And then people see the tree
shaking and they know, okay,
it has a slightly different shake.
I'd like to be a, no,
I'd like to be a grizzly
because I admire their speed,
their strength, their beauty.
I'd also like to occasionally
just lose it on a camper.
(chuckling)
You just want to rip a head off.
Yeah, they forgot to tie their Slim Jim
and hoist it up into a tree
before they went to their tent.
Yeah, I'd love to do that.
It's just rip open the tent and go,
(Conan growls)
(chuckling)
Like I'm doing a practical joke, yeah.